[Music]
along with a fun and fast female driven
comedy this week is another installment
in a popular horror franchise a new
animated series featuring the only
superhero truly worthy of the word super
a Netflix legal drama that's in session
for round two and an rt25 pick that will
only feel like the end of the world
we're not just here to save the day
we're here to save your whole week this
is what to watch I love a grand
adventure oh hi so nice to see an
American what do you do for work if the
cops are doing a back check
crashing into the theaters is the comedy
flick Joyride a strong and funny female
cast is the first reason to check this
one out with stars Stephanie Shu Sherry
Cola and Ashley Park leading the way it
revolves around four unlikely friends
who end up on a very wild International
Adventure that not only bonds them but
teaches them a few things along the way
this is the directorial debut for Adele
Lim who previously co-wrote the
certified fresh films crazy Rich Asians
and Raya and The Last Dragon meaning
she's got mad skills and that's the
second reason to see this one plus with
Seth Rogen and Evan Goldberg serving as
producers the laughs are big and they
are raunchy but hey critics don't seem
to mind as this one is hovering around
the low 90s on the Tomato Meter oh joy
ride it's in a coma but I don't remember
being sick we're ready to forget
ever since then I see crazy stuff with
my dreams
also creaking in the theaters this week
is the horror film Insidious The Red
Door this may be the fifth installment
in the Insidious franchise but this one
is a direct sequel to 2010's Insidious
and 2013's Insidious Chapter 2 with the
main stars returning like Patrick Wilson
and Rose Byrne which is the first reason
to consider this one plus speaking of
Wilson another reason to come walking
through the red door is that he is also
doing his thing behind the camera for
this film as it marks his directorial
debut and while only one Insidious film
is fresh on the Tomato Meter so far
where this franchise has made its Mark
is at the box office where pretty much
all the movies have done well that of
course means the fans are liking what
they are seeing and are going back for
more I can do this I'm gonna hide my
powers and be a normal man having a
normal day
starting now
flying onto our TV radar is the new
animated series my adventures with
Superman and the first obvious reason to
watch this one is simple Superman
anytime the Man of Steel is involved
it's got potential for greatness it's
Justice League sorry on top of that
Clark can't slash Superman is being
voiced by Jack Quade best known as Huey
from the boys gotta love the acting
range there while rising star and
YouTuber Alice Lee is the voice of Lois
Lane in other words it's a great base
for this voice cast and fans of Superman
lore will be happy to know that this
series will bring in all kinds of
popular characters from past media like
Supergirl Brainiac Heat Wave Deathstroke
Amanda Waller and more the show's
creators were looking to explore their
early years of Clark and Lois and Jimmy
Olsen at the Daily Planet and looked at
the 1978 film Superman as a major
influence and I mean anytime Christopher
Reeves Superman can provide inspiration
we're in Mickey holler with the hottest
defense attorney in La art at work you
mean that stupid magazine ooh fantastic
yeah you know I don't care about that
stuff
making the case for your viewing time as
well is the second season of Lincoln
Lawyer this Netflix drama series is
coming off a certified fresh first
season where both the Tomato Meter and
audience scores are around 80 percent
super solid call that exhibits a and 1A
for why to watch another would be a
reminder that this character and series
are based on novels by Michael Connolly
much like the running Bosch on Prime
clearly Mr Connolly's books make great
television I mean who else comes up with
a lawyer that works in the back of his
chauffeured Lincoln Navigator instead of
an office wait is that a thing that we
can do on top of that the series was
created for television by David E Cali
who had a hand in making oh a million
great shows like Doogie Hauser MD and
big little lies and so many in between
and seriously how many times have you
asked someone what they're watching and
Lincoln Lawyer gets mentioned plenty I'd
say it's worth a look it's a meteor
shower
this new one you're tracking
it's what we call a global killer
nothing would survive not even bacteria
and finally our rt25 picks celebrating
25 years of Rotten Tomatoes is
Armageddon released 25 years ago this
week the film was directed by Michael
Bay who also produced alongside Jerry
Bruckheimer and when you pair those two
names together in 1998 the result is
gonna be a money maker as in the second
highest grossing film in the U.S that
year behind Saving Private Ryan and the
highest grossing worldwide with over 550
million dollars made and if that kind of
success isn't reason enough to drill
into this one here's a little something
to tickle the Nostalgia Armageddon
received four Oscar nominations
including one for best original song for
Aerosmith's I don't want to miss a thing
you know the song that plays during the
cheesiest romantic moment ever between
Ben Affleck and Liv Tyler and some
animal crackers a third reason to look
back at this one is that the audience
score is at a solid 73 percent pair that
with the fact that the Tomato Meter
score while rotten has climbed a good
five percent Through The Years thanks to
more critical reviews of the time being
found and implemented into the Tomato
Meter Gotta Love Math baby
okay that's it five picks coming at you
like a giant meteorite and were the
Drillers breaking it all down for you or
something like that anyway be sure to
let us in your fellow viewers know in
the comments what you did check out
whether it was on this list or not
remember to hit up rottentomatoes.com
for the latest updates on scores and
reviews for everything mentioned as well
as the movie and TV World At Large and
while you're there check out the rt25
page where we're celebrating 25 years of
Rotten Tomatoes it'll make you feel
young again I swear that's all for today
fresh family until next week stay fresh
[Music]
foreign